[Music]
i was born on the 17th day
of january 1846
i go back as far
as way along the early 50s
my first recollection
of public living and especially
political living as i call it was when i
learned as a boy of nine or ten that my
home was in in the state of virginia
i didn't know about states before that
time
then
time passed pretty rapidly because i was
attending high school
and i remember distinctly
the occasion when the
john brown
the poor man
sought freedom for the slaves
then came up the great struggle
when the republican party
had become a
power in the land
in 1860
mr lincoln was elected as you know
and i remember
that there was a good deal of excitement
in my
section now
i was attending school as i said
and when in the
spring
spring of 61
when uh news came
that war was actually declared in fact
it had been coming when south carolina
as we heard seceded from the union
well
wonder now what mr lincoln will do
when he is
seated on the presidential chair
well there was a variety
of feeling about it even among our 75
100 young men boys
at school
but right at once and what was declared
about half of our pupils young men over
18
quid school
joined companies
of the infantry cavalry
and in their homes and surrounding
counties and in that vicinity
i want to go too
but my father said now son
you're too young i was just 15.
yes let's pass
and
if the war continues long enough you may
have an opportunity
well so i arrested
and the war began and i heard about it
and i heard that william battle of
williamsburg some of my classmates fell
in the battle there well i grieved about
that because they were boys that i've
been brought up with they were a little
older than i
but
i felt sorry that they were killed
then in 62
although general lee
had still a pretty good army
he began to need
more men
naturally although the big battles uh
the largest letters had not come yet
but my neighbors around there some of
them who were over 45 kinsmen of mine
some of them
began to
just get up to get up a company of
cavalry
and i a boy
of
16 and a half years old
joined the cavalry company which
afterwards was attached and
counted with others
among the 24th virginia cavalry
now for a long time then from over 62 on
until
64.
red battles had been fought in there we
heard the battle of gettysburg
and finally our core our camp company
was taken away from the black water
border
guarding this that section of the
country from the infraction incursions
of federal soldiers who might cross the
blackwater river and show on and come
over into confederate territory
we were taken in the spring of 64 our
regiment was
uh in the neighborhood of petersburg
and while
we were camp just north of petersburg
general grant began his invasion of that
part of virginia we heard about it and i
remember very distinctly one morning
we heard that general lee had crossed
james up north and was coming down the
ten pike road to in the direction of
petersburg just near us
and
the next morning
happening to look how i was on guard
across the james river there we saw long
lines of blue
at the infantry of the
the army in the united states flags on
the other side of the james coming down
to the beyond the mouth of the
appomattox river that flows into the
genes
in order to cross on the pontoon bridges
and thus begin the invasion of
that part of virginia
and in the city of petersburg
thus
i was not with that part of the army my
regiment was
moved up north of virginia out of
richmond i mean
north of richmond and thus we guided
that city for several months while
general lee and general grant were
struggling
there near petersburg
while that was going on there were some
skirmishes
and one well small battle i was in i was
not in any of the large larger battles
probably fortunately maybe unfortunately
well general uh
daryl you will commanded the
the donald lee's corps
near richmond
and i remember we were called up one day
and took the davidtown road
and some mile or two i don't know we
never counted distances of time in those
days
we turned off from the road main road
and went down a road through wood
afterwards came to an opening and
there was a line
of blue boys and with some artillery
and we charged them
and that's where i was struck the first
and only time in my leg which led me up
uh two months
i sent home on furlough
now i want to bring in one or two little
points there
that might be sort of interesting some
we were around richmond my regiment was
all the time then
on doing little of nothing
although that war was still going on
and after a while a saturday evening
the first day of april
1865.
we were ordered
and by the way in the meantime
about half of my regiment had lost their
horses
the confederate soldiers own their own
horses and when they lost the horse it
was difficult at that stage to secure a
substitute
anyhow i lost mine i've forgotten just
now how
i don't don't lift i don't believe it's
in battle however at that time
now orders came for a dismounted part or
d-mounted i might say
other arrangement to fall in line and
march
we stopped on the way
and spent the night
at a saturday night the next day was a
beautiful day sunday
we didn't know what was going on we were
we were within a mile of richmond
and there was a turmoil there
and that day
as you all know
that day
the
president davis was attending his usual
services at his church
in saint paul's church
right in the midst of the sermon
this door front door opened
and a courier
rushed in
and read it went up to president davis
had it in the paper
he opened it and it was a dispatch from
general lee saying mr president
i am so heavily oppressed
by the enemy that i'm compelled to
abandon petersburg
mr davis rose
and left
and this the public the
congregation broke up and in a few
minutes almost
it was
pandemonium then in richmond
we marched out of richmond
early the next morning
on the third
and started in a southeasterly direction
i really know which way uh which way now
where we were going but afterwards it
showed that we were attempting on the
general u.s command
to
come in contact with general lee
somewhere down uh southwest of
petersburg
well the federals under general sheridan
overtook us
our command of about three thousand
at intermedia
at emilia county virginia
and after fighting several hours
why general europe surrendered us and
thus i became a captain
i went
to prison along with this command
and
we landed in point lookout maryland down
here
now
comes up the question
of what we southern soldiers fought for
my friends as a boy
of 16 and a half years old
i didn't think about any of abolition of
slavery
my mind wasn't developed enough to take
in what the politicians had in mind
and hence
there was no trouble as to the freedom
of the slaves
the south
did not fight
for
the preservation or extension of slavery
now fairness was a great curse on this
country that we had slavery and i thank
god that i did not bring up my boys
and girls
under a system of slavery only which i
was brought under
what did you boys fight for then
here's what
that many people do not know
that as a young man that way i couldn't
understand it fully but i look back now
and see my
part in it
and so what we struggle for and that was
for states rights
our state's rights
and as that many of you knew immediately
after the war
their rights to the various states well
especially in the south were very much
curtailed if i use that word
and since then i have noticed
you let things come up
that
encroach on the ordinary states rights
which we have preserved
and we find
that the north
the boys that wore the blue with us in
preservation of the state's rights
you